お願いします えーと 今までは
あの 普通の生命に起こる
まあできてる まあ働いている心のいろいろなところは説明しました
そこで あの ルーパ・アヴィチリ・チッタといって
この色界の心と それからアルーパ・アヴィチリ・チッタといって
無色界の心っていうのは
それも普通の生命に起こりますけど
特別に訓練しないと起こらない心として
瞑想の心 禅定の心として種類から説明します
で カーマ・アヴィチリ・チッタとカーマ・アヴィチリ
欲界心ですか 欲界心はあります
欲界心だけはどんな生命にも一般的に
あの 起こる 回転する心の働きなんです
で その説明も全部終わりました
で 心 で 心っていうのは生命っていうことだから
あの 心の働きを見て生命のことを理解することもできるし
それからこの出色 じゃなくて色界・無色界という考え方がありますから
まあ生命の次元が我々にはもう認識できないかもしれませんけど
すごい高い次元の生命になっちゃう
人間の場合は 人間にはそれどんな心も作ることは可能なんです
ですから 論理的に言えば
人間だけじゃなくて どんな生命にも心を成長することは可能なはずなんです
だといっても 心は体に依存しているんだから
環境に依存しているんだから
その環境に体に条件付けられちゃって
付けられると いろんなことをできなくなるんですね
まあ例えば皆様方でも大変重大な仕事を自分に回されたら
仕事自体は大変大事で
そうするとその条件があるんだから
他のやることはもう押さえなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
もしかすると 自然的に言えば夜になったら寝なくちゃいけない
でも この与えられた仕事は大変大事なことで
寝るわけにはいかない
寝ないで仕事をしなくちゃいけないとか
そういうふうに我々は条件付けられちゃったら
まあどうしようもなくなっちゃうんですね
例えば 偉い人々なんかは瞑想なんかしたくても
あまり偉くて暇がなくてできるわけじゃないんですね
ですから 不可能ということではなくて
この条件によってもうできない
たまにものすごい頭の人々がいるんですね
人間の中で 本当に鋭くて
だから頭すごく鋭くて活動するんだから
それなりにいろいろ世俗的なことをやってしまっちゃって
それですごい忙しくなって
すごく偉くなりまして
まあ時間いろんなことをやっているんだよ
そうすると瞑想なんかする暇もないし
その世界全く知らないことになってしまっちゃうし
だから論理的にはどんな生命にも自分の心を成長することは可能なんですけど
残念ながらその生まれている環境やら場所やら
持っている体やら いろんなことによってまあできなくなるだけ
ですから 犬にでも猫にでも別にヴィパッサナー瞑想すれば悟れないかということは取れないと言えるはずがないんですよ
でも犬だから猫だからそれできないんですね
その体だから その体で決められている範囲の中でしか行動できない
ですから その生命がその体を捨てて違う条件を作るしか方法ないんです
ですから 犬が死んで人間にならない限りは
もう瞑想っていうのはできない
できない じゃあ神々には瞑想できるかというと
できることはできるんですよ
でも神々になったところで
とことん喜びで楽しくて楽しい波動で生きていなきゃ生きていられないんですね
人間で言えば 我々はすーっと酸素を吸わなきゃ死んでしまっちゃうんですね
だから瞑想 これからヴィパッサナー瞑想しますから分呼吸をやめてくださいって言ったら
もう呼吸やめる瞑想する前に人が死んでしまっちゃうんですね
ですから 神々の世界になっちゃうと
彼らがこの五根をとことん楽しませてあげなくちゃいけないんです
それとヴィパッサナー瞑想というのはなかなかもう合わないんですね
だから神々に瞑想してくださいというのは
もう死んでくださいという
自殺してくださいということと同じになってしまっちゃうんですね
自殺したらもうこちらに意味がないんだから
そういうことで この条件によって生命にはいろいろドラマがあるんです
自分生きてる次元によりまして
そういうことで この輪廻の中で
我々はわずかな瞬間だけ人間になるんですね
人間になるのはほんのわずかな瞬間なんです
これこの年長いとか思ったら
それは大違いなんですよ
仏教ではこの劫年という単位で計算しているんだからね
そこで 1 光年というのは
宇宙一つ出来上がって消えるぐらいの長い時間で
そういうのはもう何兆回も数えられるんですから
ですから この 宇宙自体がね
ビッグバンからビッグバンまで一つで 1 光年だというならば
そういうものは何万 何百万回とか何千万回繰り返していく間で
もうじゃあそれの時間と我々の 60年
70年というのは比べられますかね
ですから ほんの瞬間で
我々は人間でいて その次元ではいろんなことをできる時なんですね
ほんの瞬間しかない そこでできなかったら
またまあしょうがない
またいつ人間に戻るかということはもう知ったわけじゃないんですからね
なかなか難しいんです
人間の数っていうのはすごい少ないんだから
で 宇宙にはいろいろ生命あるんですけどね
仏教経典ではなくて 文学ではこのいろんなところの生命にも仏教は教えているんだという
お釈迦様も教えていたんだとあるんだけど
まあそれは私たちはわからないし
そこで我々行って生まれ変わるかというと
それも一応不可能なんですね
なぜかと 人間っていうのは
我々こちらで固まっているし
こちらに執着があるんだから
もうある一定の決まっている星で生まれてしまっちゃうんですね
違う星で生まれ変わってみようとかね
そういう希望する人はほとんどないでしょう
ですから まあそういう我々は人間の次元で生まれ変わらなくちゃいけないというようになっていて
それは人間というのは数が少ないんだから
すごい少ない 数が少ないし
寿命は短いし これ至難の業ですね
だからほんの瞬間で頑張らなくちゃいけないってことになってて
神に神々の次元に生まれたら
もうものすごい長い時間生きていられますけど
やっぱりそこの問題は体の状態なんですね
彼らは硬い物体として身体が持っていない
ほとんど精神的なもので出来上がっている体を持っていて
ヨーロッパ人がそれはなんかね
アストラルボディとか何とかとかね
スピリチュアルボディとかなんとか言ってますけど
それはでも物質的な体ですけど
そういう体は別に食べ物で支えられているわけじゃなくて
心から与えてあげるこの刺激で生きているんですね
それを機能しなくなっちゃうんですね
瞑想なんか始めたら ですから
やっぱりかわいそうに死んでしまいます
だからやらないんです
結構神々がいるんだそうですね
仏教に対してすごい興味持っていて
ありがたいと思っていて
ありがたいなと思っているだけで
自分では何もできない
そういう習慣で 仏教の信者さんがいつでも神々に回向するんですね
修行して その徳 功徳を神々に与えてあげますと
助けてあげているんですね
いわゆる助けてあげると偉そうなことというよりは
仏教というのは何でも分かってやって
みんな仲良く 私が持っているものはみんなに分かって分けてあげて
仲良くやろうってやりましょうという気持ちで
自分には修行できたんだから
あの人々に修行できないんだから
じゃあ与え しましょうと
他の世界である一般的な神々をお祈りすることとは
ちょっと仏教の人々のやり方はちょっとわずかに立場が違うんですね
それすごい仲良く自分を持ってるとこを与えてあげる
そこで向こうもいろいろ能力を持ってるんだから
それはいくらかこちらにもくれるだろうと
それぐらいの感じで とにかく心っていうのは育てられるものなんですが
だからといって無条件に育てられるかというと
そこもないんですね 瞑想にしたっても
瞑想はいくら頑張って瞑想しているんだからといって進むわけでもないんです
私は毎日頑張ってるんだとか
毎日頑張ってるんだからと言ったっても進むわけじゃないし
いい加減やってるんだからと言ったっても進まないわけでもないし
体と心の条件揃っちゃったらすぐそこでもう進んでしまっちゃうんですね
いくら例えば年 年 年瞑想しているんだという人にしても
何か自分の身の回りに何か出来事起きたら
例えば自分が予想しなかったこと
何かあったならば そのショックで結構心がまた違う波動がしてしまっちゃうし
その間は瞑想なんかはできっこはないんですね
ですから その条件にものすごく左右されるんですね
心っていうのは そういうことで
とにかく気をつけて 長い目で見て
徐々に自分に 体にも親切に
心にも親切に あまりやり過ぎもなくて
怠けることもなく すごく中道を守って
いつでもいいコンディションで体と心をね
保ちながら修行するということは必要なんですね
ですから この悟りの世界っていうのは
もうものすごい難しい体験得がたいようなことになってるんです
人間に生まれなくちゃいけないし
人間に生まれだっても
こういう風な機会に出会うかないか
それまたもうわからないし
出会ったっても 自分の体のコンディションはどうですか
心の状態はどうですかと
それまた大変であるし
我々には生きてるんだから何が起こるか分からないでしょうに
親戚は死んでしまっちゃうわ
子供は死ぬかもしれませんし
家は火事になるかもしれませんし
地震が起こるかもしれません
何か分からない 誰にどんなことが起こるかと
そういうものを起きちゃったら
せっかく仏教に出会ってももう瞑想するところじゃないんですね
私たちも 例えば自分の親やら誰かが死んじゃって悲しんでるって
あんたそんな泣くんじゃなくて瞑想しなさいというバカはいないんですよ
お坊さんたちは言わない
他の人言ってるかは分かりませんだけど
我々は言わない その時はそうですねとかね
その人一緒になって そういう世間話でもして
その時はしょうがないんですね
で 例えばお金がなくなっちゃって
すごいもう倒産したならば
もうそれだったらもう何か金儲けの話でもしてあげたりするんですよ
仏教をもちましては金儲けは良くないんだとかね
そんな話はもう通じないんですよ
ですから このまあ そういうことで
体のコンディションと心のコンディションというものも揃わなくちゃいけない
そこで いくら体がコンディションにいいと言っていても
いつ崩れるか分からないんですよ
ちょっとしたことで 体のコンディションもガラッと崩れてしまっちゃうし
ちょっと食べたものによって
あるいは吸ってる空気によってでもね
我々感じないだけですけど
空気っていうのは結構汚れてるでしょ
たまに自分の部屋にすごい汚れてる空気が入る
匂いもないしわからない
でもなんとなく体の調子が悪い
すごくなんかイライラしているとかね
その時は瞑想したっても
もう瞑想自体が嫌いになってるだけのことで
そこで本当は自分の瞑想する時間かもしれません
そうするともうどこかへ外行って自然新鮮な空気を吸うか何とかしなくちゃいけないし
ですからこのコンディションというのはもうなかなか揃わないっていうかね
ですからこの本当のこと言うと
このこれもう0にほとんど近いんですよ
この確率性っていうのは
それぐらい理解しておかないと
悟れるとか悟れるぐらいのこの心の状態
心と体のコンディションが全部揃うということは
この宇宙のスケールで物事を考えるとそれは分かりますよ
お釈迦様はこう言ってますから
一人の人が自分の一人の母のために泣いた涙集めても
海の水よりは多いんだと
それぐらい輪廻転生しているんだと
キリがないんだと そこで我々は一回の人生で母が亡くなったんだからといって
どれぐらいバケツ杯ぐらい涙流すんですかね
ないでしょうに いくら泣いたってもね
ほんのあそこなんのガラスいっぱい涙も出ませんだから
ですから どれぐらい長い間いたんですかということはもうわかるし
そこで 修行になったらまたこの人生の中でもこのコンディション
条件揃うということは結構難しいんですからね
ですからパーリ語でこういう言葉があるんです
これお釈迦様の言葉なんですけど
カナンゴウパッチャガという
ゴっていうのはあなた方は
これちょっとした言葉遣いみたいなこと
だから汝らというふうな訳は一番ぴったしなんですね
あなた方はカナン この瞬間
この出会い その機会という意味なんです
カナンというのは瞬間という意味なんです
この瞬間 意味としてはこの出会い
マっていうのはなかれと命令形でするなかれと
ウパッチャガというの何でしたっけ？失うなかれと
パスしなくてはいけないんだと
失うなと 汝らはこの瞬間を失う
失うなかれというふうな
これでこの瞬間っていうのは
この人生で生まれて 釈尊に出会って
いい体を持って いい知識を持って
健康的で ほどほど豊かで悩みのない瞬間はたまに現れるんですね
それはもう輪廻の次元から
次元から見ると もう本当に瞬間なんですね
それをもう無駄にするなと
という意味で ですから
お釈迦様はよく考えておっしゃっているものなんです
カナンゴウマウパッチャガ
サヤドーの説法にあったドゥルバドゥルバっていうのは
そこをサヤドー教えたがってるんです
なかなか通訳はもう揃わなくて
みんなに分からなくなっちゃったんだけど
ドゥルバというのはもう得難い
もうものすごい難しいもの
4つあるんだと それ4つもあなた方に揃ってるんだということを
もういわゆる我々を励ますためにしっかり頑張ってくださいと
これ大事な時間だよと
4つあるんだよと そういうことで
一応 これは全部序論なんですけど
この修行するのはいいんですけど
まあとにかく皆様方は大変珍しい
人間にはなかなかできないことはもうに出会っていることは確かなんですね
それで自慢して よく誰にもできないことをやってるんだとかね
で もうちょっとなんて言いますか
余計な自信ついちゃったら
また何か失う可能性あるんです
ですから もうそれでも難しいんだと思った方がいいと思ってますね
ですから このそれぐらい悟りの境地って難しいんです
禅定の境地も結構難しいんだけど
でもかなり大勢の人々には禅定は作られます
色界無色界っていうのは
色界ぐらいはね もう頑張れば作られないわけないんですね
で 悟りの境地っていうのは
さらにそれよりはすごく難しいんです
仏教では それ言うと仏教自体もなんとなくすごい損はしますけど
でもこれは心理であって普遍的な教えであって
でなければ全ての人々に門を開いておけなくちゃいけないんだけど
それは確実に全ての生命には門は開いてますよ
宗教ではないんだから
特別に宗教に浸透しなさいということでもないんだから
誰がやったっても構いませんし
キリスト教の人であろうが
白人であろうが黒人であろうが
誰がやったっても同じことなんですが
まあ全部条件揃わなきゃ起きない出来事なんですね
ですから 論理的な状態と実践的な状態っていうのは結構違いますでしょ
科学の世界でも同じですから
科学の世界で論理的には我々にはいろんなことできるんだけど
でも実際にはできない
例えばエネルギーの問題がありまして
それは核反応してエネルギー起こすとエネルギーはあるんだけど
それはとんでもない危険なものだと
地球は自分で自分自身を殺すことになっちゃいますよと知っている
じゃあ危険のないエネルギーは何ですかと
核反応するんじゃなくて
核を融合することなんですね
核反応を起こして分裂するんじゃなくて
核をまとめて 一瞬 何て言いますか
太陽で起こる 起きる 起こるような
このフュージョンですね
あれは 融合 融合した方が一番きれいなエネルギーが出てくるんだと
きれいだけじゃなくて
ものすごい抜群のエネルギーが出てくる
方法も知ってますよ 地球にはもう腐るほど水素
水素があるし それは融合させちゃえばいくらでもエネルギーはできますけど
それは論理的にはできるんだけど
実践では全然できない
何 1,000万円の機械かけても
ものすごいほんのわずかな融合だけ
でっかい実験室で 職場なんかあるんだからね
ほんの瞬間 それを試してみるということはやってます
それはもう工業用にはもう絶対ならないんですよ
だから まあそういうふうなものなんですよ
心の問題も体の問題 物質の世界
じゃあ そういうことで今日のお話に入ります
今日は出世間心 ローコーッタラって言うんですね
ローコーッタラチッタ
出世間心 で ここでローカという言葉がございまして
これでウッタラという言葉があって
それでまとめてその言葉を使っているんです
ローカとウッタラ 合体させたところでローコーッタラになるんです
ローカっていうのは世界ということで
まあこの物質的な世界というよりは
生命 仏教で生命にもローカという世界というんです
宇宙の物質的な物体にもローカというんですね
また 物体と関係なく生命という意味でもローカという言葉を使っているのです
ですから 存在 存在の存在という次元ですね
ウッタラっていうのは乗り越えたと
存在ということはもう乗り越えたっていうことで
超越したんだと もう存在ではありません
生命でもありません いかなる生命でもない
生命の次元を その枠を乗り越えたという
ウッタラっていうのは乗り越えたという意味
ですから このローコーッタラの意味はそういうことで
日本語では簡単に出世間と
世間を脱出したということで出たと
ですから 用語の方が単純なんです
本当の意味はなかなかもう難しいんですね
出世間の意味は 生命の次元を乗り越えたと
もう生命でなくなったということなんです
はっきり言えば 生命で亡くなったと言っちゃったら
言葉上ではなんかもう興味
教務所見たいですね  なんか否定的な言葉ですね
ですから それを使わないで乗り越えたという肯定的な言葉を使うんです
生きることをやめなさいと言っちゃったら
誰でも嫌がっちゃうでしょうに
例えば悟った人はもう二度と生まれ変わりませんと
どこにも生まれ変わりませんって言うんですね
それを言われると 仏教の話を聞いていると
なんか首をひねっちゃうんです
どこに生まれ変わらなかったら
なんでそんなに苦労しなくちゃいけないんですか
いいところに生まれ変わりたいのにとかね
と思うんです それは正直にみんな思うんですね
こんなに一生懸命いいことをしているんだからね
まあご褒美としていいところに生まれ変わりたいんだけど
悟っちゃったらどこに生まれ変わらないんだったら
もったいないんではないかと思ったりする
それはまあ言葉でどこにも生まれ変わりませんよと言ったら
やっぱりなんとなくこの言葉扱いではね
このポジティブ的に扱うか
否定的に扱うかということはありますからね
やっぱりそのどちらかというとポジティブ的な言葉を扱った方がいいんですよ
人を叱るときでも 否定的な言葉で叱るよりは肯定的な言葉で叱ると
人をどうしようもなく批判しなくちゃいけないと
その時でも否定的な言葉ではなくて
肯定的な言葉で批判するとか
そういうふうにすると結構結果はいいんですね
悪い結果は得られないんです
でも 人間には否定的な言葉っていうのはすごく使いやすいんです
ですから もうすぐ否定的な言葉を使うんですね
それで我々は結構悩んでるんです
上司に叱られたんだと
それは上司が否定的な言葉で叱られたんだから
もう心が傷んでいるだけであって
肯定的な言葉で叱ったならば
何のことなく相手が元気になっちゃうんですね
ですから この言葉遣いの場合も
できるだけ仏教の世界ではできるだけ肯定的な言葉を使って
だからって言ってなんだかんだはいはい
それはそうです それはそうですというバカな聞き方ではないんです
批判するものは批判する
叱るべきところは叱る
厳しく言うべき時は厳しく言う
でも全部肯定的な言葉を使うと
それは仏教において優しい言葉というんです
それちょっと頭に入れておけば人生変わりますよ
社会で結構うまく成功している人々の言葉を聞いてみてください
人間関係がうまくいっている人々は
仕事やら会社やら普通の社会の行動やら
何でもすごく上手にうまくいっている人々が
すごい人気ある人々とか
ほとんどみんな生まれつき肯定的な言葉を使っているんじゃないかと
その人々の秘密は何を喋ろうとすごく肯定的な言葉で
批判する時でも肯定的な言葉で人をバカにして蹴落とす
時でも使っている言葉は肯定的な言葉で
ですから 悪い結果が出てこない
そういうことで この涅槃の説明しようと思うところでも
結構仏教を仏教を説明する人々は
たまに簡単にどこに生まれ変われませんよというのはいとも簡単なんです
輪廻転生しませんよと
例えばそれはすごい否定的な言葉なんですね
そうすると なんかみんなここまで修行して
どこに生まれ変わらない
何も得られないために一生懸命頑張らなくちゃいけない
何もするな それでは最初から頑張らなくちゃいけないかとか
人は努力する 何か得たいんだから努力するでしょうと
というのは普通なんですね
そこをそういうふうに考えちゃって
涅槃という世界を作っちゃったんですね
後で人々が 涅槃会とか言ったりして
仏教用語に出てくるんです
もう南方仏教ではないんだけど
気持ちは分かりますよ
やっぱりあの否定的な言葉でやられているんだと
そこで涅槃という世界があって
そこで永遠にブッダがいて
まあ楽しい場所がある
そこに行きたがっているんだ
そう言われると 結局涅槃ではなくなっちゃうし
輪廻そのままになっちゃいますよ
どこかにいるわけじゃないんだから
でも涅槃について否定的な言葉を使ってしまって
簡単に説明しようと思ったんだから
そうなっちゃうんですね
だといっても 涅槃ということは説明はできない
説明できたならば それは涅槃ではありません
説明できるものは全部我々の知識で
言葉でなくても 我々の体験で掴めるものなんですね
体験で掴めるものはすべてが存在の次元なんです
存在の次元の体験を使って
言葉を使って 存在を乗り越えていることを説明はもう不可能なんです
ですから 涅槃には言葉がない
ですから お釈迦様は全部説明して
涅槃のところに行く場合は
そこで止まってくださいと相手に言うんです
言葉はここまでだと 話し合いはここまでだと
理解はここまでだと ある人はもう徐々に徐々に説明し続けていたんですね
人は悪いことをしたらどうなるんですかと
悪いことをやめたらどうなる？いいことってどういうことですかと
そういういいことしたらどうなるんですか？とか
それからじゃあそれ以上のいいことはありますか？そういう瞑想とかいろいろあったりして説明してくれるんですね
で それでその瞑想したら次にどうなるんですか？と
それだったらこういうこういう戦場があります
それをやったらどうなりますかと
まあそこでまあ戦場の世界の最高なところまで行って
まあそれそれ以上進めたい進めたければどうなるんです？って言ったら
それだったら心にこの煩悩というものは完全に消えるような方法をやらなくちゃいけないんだと
じゃあ煩悩が完全に消えたところで
その人の心はどうなるんですか？と最後に聞くんですよ
したら あなたは質問しすぎだと
そこでストップしなさいと
質問はここまで 言葉はここまで
話し合いはここまで 涅槃という目的を目指して
それを得るためにこの修行法はあるんだと
そこで話は終わっちゃうんです
その場合でも お釈迦様は素晴らしく肯定的だなと僕は感じたんですね
なぜならば 涅槃という目的があって
そのための修行方法だよと
じゃあ涅槃って何者かと聞いちゃったら
もうそれはもうやめなさいと
言葉はそれ以上は進めないんだと
人間の経験はそれ以上は進めないんだ
いわゆる生命の経験 ですから
それを体験するしかない
体験した人から教えてもらうかというと
とんでもないんです お釈迦様からも教えてもらわなかったんだから
それは個人個人が体験する
体験したら もう二度と人に説明してあげようとは思わない
説明したい気持ちもないんです
なぜならば 説明したがる何か心の中で何か感情がある時でしょ
いいものを見ましたよと
で もう感情があって これ言いたくて言いたくてしょうがなくなっちゃうんですね
そういう一切の感情消えたんだから
だから言わない だからうるさく瞑想しているんだ
こういうことあるんだ
こういう経験があるんだという人々は
自分たちがものすごい未熟だ未熟だと言っていることなんです
本人がそういうことをわかってないだけで
進めれば進むほど人は喋れなくなるんです
喋れなくなっちゃうんです
もう言いたい気持ちも消えていっちゃうし
落ち着くというかね  [背景音楽]それは涅槃の世界で
とにかくこの涅槃の世界を説明する場合は
いわゆる肯定的に説明した方が無難なんです
世間 世間の次元 生命の次元を乗り越えたと
乗り越えた心 ですから
我々の心とは全く違うし
我々は生命でいる限り
その心はもう生まれないです
それからこれから私は説明しますけど
これからする説明も全部欲界の言葉で欲界の認識でする説明であって
もう涅槃の説明ではないんです
これは禅宗ではいい例えを使って
この絵に描いた餅 絵に描いた餅と餅というのはもう何の関係もない
全く違うものでしょうに
ですから 餅とは本当は関係ない
絵だから似ているかもしれませんだけど
香りもないし味もないし
試しにちょっとサンプルみたいに試食してみようと思ったっても
絵ではまるっきりできませんでしょうに
絵は絵であって もう一つ使っている例えというのは
これは今禅の例えというのは結構立派な文学的な作品がいっぱいありますから
テーラワーダのテキストを使う時でも
たまたまそういうのは引用したりする
一つはこの Finger pointing to the moon
お月様に指してる指だと
お月様あっちだよと言ってるだけであって
指は指であって 月様とは全然関係ないんですね
だからこの涅槃の世界
悟りの世界の説明っていうのは
お月様はあっちだよと見せている指だけであります
餅でいえば もうあれは特別な発想もあります
画びょうとかなんとか高い線で
で  絵で描いた餅と同じですということ
それで違う形のもう一つ例えはありますね
あの 何といいますか あの絵に描いた猫でもネズミは取ればいいんじゃないかっていう
その場合は違うことを言って
涅槃のことを言ってるわけじゃないんです
あの なんとかお坊さんがもう猫の絵ばっかり描いて
それでネズミたちが逃げてしまっちゃった
もうそれでいいんじゃないかと
その場合は方法論のことを言ってるんです
方法についてむちゃくちゃ言うなと
どんな瞑想法がいいんですか？結跏趺坐した方がいいんですか？半跏趺坐でいいんですか？ああだこうだよく喋るんですね
どんな道場の方法はいいんですかとかね
あんなものはすべてくだらないんです
どんな方法 立ってでも座ってでも寝てでも結果出せと
猫は土で作っても粘土で作っても
絵で描いたっても 生きている猫でもどうでもいいんです
ネズミさえ取ってくれれば
そこで方法についてくだらないことを言うなというすごい智慧なんですね
禅の物語で言っているのは
じゃあ六処智っといえば
八つあります そういうソーターパーティ
ソーターパッティマッガ
サクダガーミマッガ アナガーミマッガ
アラハッタマッガという四つがありまして
また次の四つは同じでパラと言うんですね
ソーターパッティマッガチッタと言わなくちゃいけないんですけど
ソーターパッティマッガチッタン
ソーターパッティパラチッタンと
上書いときます チッタという言葉
こちらにつなげてこちらにつなげてみれば
ソーターパッティマッガチッタン
ソーターパッティパラチッタン
ですからソーターパッティという言葉は一つこちらにつなげるし
一つこちらにつなげるし
それで一応テキストとしてはできちゃうんですね
同じ言葉を繰り返さなくちゃいけないんだからね
マッガなくたっていいし
ソーターパッティマッガチッタ
ソーターパッティパラチッタ
サキダーガーミマッガチッタ
サキダーガーミパラチッタ
アナガーミマッガチッタ
アナガーミパラチッタ
サキダーガーミじゃなくてサカダーガーミですね
こちらどちらが正しいかな
これはテキストにサカッと書いてますからいいにしましょう
経典での出てくる言葉はちょっと思い浮かばないんです
サキダーガーミという言葉を思い出しますからね
先入は これは経典じゃないんだからね
とにかくサカダーガーミマッガチッタ
アナガーミマッガチッタ
パラチッタ その八つの心は悟りの心
出世間の心 で と言うてもこれは心だから
この心自体が生命ということだから
それまた出世間だけじゃないんです
ですから これに出世間心というのは心の成長の終わり
生命としての最後の心って意味で
輪廻の中の生命として苦しんでいる
展開してもう回転して苦しんでいて
そこでもう最後の瞬間のもう苦しみのすべてのもの
最後の心ですね ですから
心自体は生命の次元に入っちゃうんです
で それで終わりますから
心の流れが 苦しみの流れがそれで終了しますから
出世間心というんです
だいたい説明はどこから始めればいいかな
じゃあ意味 まず大事ですね
で ソーターパッ できればこの日本語の言葉よりはこの四つぐらいでもパーリ語で覚えておいた方がいいんじゃないかな
それは仏教でこれだけなんですね
仏教は特別に世界に貢献しているのは
他のものはもう誰でも頑張れば真面目にも得られるもんなんです
今まで説明したこの色界であろうか
無色界であろうか それは仏教独特じゃないんです
この四つの心だけ仏教